Lynne starts off this hour in Tulsa
Oklahoma hi Lynne how are you hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up well I need your advice my husband
and I own the restaurants that are a
franchise I did the books and he is the
he's in the stores he mingles with the
customers and everything which he's
awesome at he's a total extrovert so my
my question is he's a rather sloppy
person and he's rather disorganized and
my question is since he represents our
company how much how important it is is
his appearance to success he he does
being such as he wears tube socks with
his nice shoes he wears out of season
clothing he where he keeps his car his
car is filthy inside and out um he has
cut his own hair just over his ears and
his hair is very straight so it makes it
stand straight out when he goes on a
business trip he carries his clothes in
a Walmart bag instead of a piece of
luggage so am I being too critical or
he's an awesome husband awesome father I
just sometimes I his appearance worries
me what do you think well I think that
you know when I when I got in to the
real estate business I was 18 years old
three weeks after I turned 18 I passed
my real-estate test that summer my
parents who ran a real estate company
gave me two or three books to read one
of them I was rereading that they'd made
me read when I was 13 how to win friends
and influence people but there was an
old book out in those days and that's a
thousand years ago right I mean this is
3040 years ago now right and so but the
book was called how to dress for success
by Steve Malloy
and the book was by Steve Malloy I don't
why do I remember that I guess just cuz
it you know it was and in those days the
way you dress for success was IBM shirt
white shirt tie dark suit you know and
people don't dress that way anymore much
unless you're on Wall Street or
something
but you know the number of people wear a
tie anymore anywhere is is very very low
in in except in certain situations what
I'm saying and even in church people
dress differently than they did back
then but that that left that impression
on me that everyone judges you initially
by your appearance it's the first
impression as they say and so yeah that
is a concern and here's the thing you
gotta here's the thing he needs to think
about is not that his wife's harping on
him about you know how he dresses
because that's like oh that's like a
federal law your wife is supposed to
harp on you about how you dress that's
federal law come on does that too okay
but that that's normal there's nothing
wrong with that but from a business
perspective one of the things I've
discovered what John Maxwell has a book
out one of my favorite leadership
writers and he's a good friend of mine
and his best-selling book and he's
written a bazillion um it's called 21
irrefutable laws of leadership and I
like the book so much that I license to
my own version of it and put a fork
wrote the foreword to it for my people
to use that's how much I believe in
those 21 laws one of the laws I believe
it's law number three is called the law
of the lid and the law of the lid in
leadership says your business will never
outgrow you you're the problem and
you're the solution with your business
so if you want your business to grow you
personally have to be growing you have
to be reading and learning things you
didn't know your to becoming a better
leader you know you have to grow because
you're the problem and if you don't grow
at all don't expect your business to
grow and what's happened is is you guys
because of your husband's wonderful
personality he has overcome his
appearance yes
but it but it's not a quirky brand it's
a distraction
and so I listen I am far from any given
any body fashion advice ever my family
laughs at me all the time just like
you're talking about okay
so but I do know when I walk into a room
with a customer or with one of my team
members that how I am dressed in my
appearance and my grooming affects the
discussion and if it's if it's
distracting if I'm coming in there
wearing 1974 tube socks to my knees
you know it's distracting and it becomes
a joke in a bad way and so because it's
such a credibility miss and so I'm
saying that as a lid on what he can
become as a businessperson as a lid on
how how great his business can be and
how much the customers can can be there
yes his appearance matters to the point
that it's not distracting and you know
people with grooming they do things that
are distracting and they do things with
their clothing that are distracting and
and so he's he you know it'd be okay if
he just didn't dress to suit you but it
was just to where nobody noticed it but
they're noticing this what you described
to me was I mean that I mean if you're
accurately describing that and I suspect
you are you know and what is he's just a
guy that's not concerned about that to
the extreme you're right you're right he
I'm not sure if he's going for the Sam
Walton look you know work no samples
better dress her than you described Sam
didn't cut his own hair
mister said mr. Sam was groomed agree
his hair didn't stick out you know I
mean their nose hairs hanging out you
know it wasn't it wasn't distracting to
sit down talk to Sam Walton and he was a
smart guy but he wasn't necessarily a
flashy dresser he wasn't spending a lot
of money on he wasn't a clothes horse he
wasn't fashion conscious and you know
virtually every guy listen to me going
yeah I got that t-shirt I got that
sweatshirt I've got one that's probably
15 years old that I wear at home you
know I mean but I don't wear it to work
right and I don't wear it on stage when
talking to people about how to handle
their money it would affect whether or
not I had credibility with them or not
even though I don't really care about
that stuff but I have to care about it
limiting or messing with my
effectiveness as a business owner and
business leader and that's why he needs
to care about this not because he needs
to have a fashion statement or not
because well haircuts don't matter well
yeah they do
yeah they do I mean when you come in
with a complete mohawk and it's pink it
matters it affects I mean if you're in a
punk rock band people go yay rah
if you're applying to be the vice
president of a bank people go you're an
idiot you're not hired you know so you
know how you dress impacts your ability
to into speak into and have credibility
with certain situations and so you know
he just doesn't want to be known as the
clown for his sake but this is different
than a wife discussion so I would put it
on a management level or a leadership
level discussion we said you copy that
book you can use you can use it to have
the discussion that leadership the law
the leadership law the lid
it helps me do things that I wouldn't
normally do for the good of my place
hold on I'll have Kelly give you one